[Musique]
je suis venu effectivement à quelques
jours du lancement du Conseil national
de la refondation sur le Bien Vieillir
ici dans un département qui est
exemplaire en matière de coordination de
l'autonomie et sur ce salon je suis venu
en quelque sorte faire le plein de
d'innovations parce qu'il y a énormément
d'innovations rencontrées aussi tous les
acteurs qui font l'accompagnement
l'autonomie le lien social sur sur les
territoires
[Musique]
j'ai vu énormément d'innovations en
termes de formation notamment plein de
d'exemples aussi de dispositifs digitaux
qui permettent à la fois d'améliorer
l'accompagnement le parcours en fait des
personnes qui sont aujourd'hui en perte
de tenue d'améliorer aussi les
conditions de travail des salariés c'est
extrêmement important bref vraiment
d'améliorer tout l'environnement ce qui
nous permet aussi d'être beaucoup plus
performant
on a une société qui qui vieillit d'ici
à 2030 les plus de 60 ans représenteront
un tiers de la population française et
donc il y a urgence à transformer en
fait notre système notre mode de
fonctionnement pour pouvoir permettre
aux personnes de bien vieillir chez elle
à domicile en particulier et puis pour
celles qui devraient aller en
établissement aussi de transformer
d'améliorer l'accompagnement dans les
EHPAD
aujourd'hui il y a des dizaines de
milliers d'emplois dans le secteur qui
sont pas pourvus et donc on cherche à
revaloriser ces professions d'un point
de vue salarial du point de vue des
parcours professionnels de la qualité de
vie au travail c'est voilà du regard
aussi qu'on porte sur ces métiers parce
que c'est des métiers qui ont énormément
de sang ce secteur c'est le quatrième
secteur pourvoyeur d'emploi en France et
donc voilà au-delà de la nécessité de
trouver des professionnels pour répondre
à un besoin social c'est aussi un
secteur qui est créateur de richesse de
valeur d'emploi et donc il faut le
soutenir
[Musique]